[music]
>> The third translation
is
the English translation and the meaning
of Al Quran, the guidance for mankind.
And the translator name is Muhammad
Farooq-e-Azam Malik.
This translation per se
I have not
gone through it.
Just little bit portion here or there.
But
people say that it's a good translation
of English. We gave to research team.
It is alhamdulillah no major problems.
No major problem means major problems
are there, but not multiple major
problems.
You know, first we have to see that how
they translate.
And there's a technique of
first understanding whether this
translation is matching with the
authentic Hadith or not. And one good
way
I don't want to reveal everything
because
something you're not meant to be told.
On the satellite, not for public, but
I'll mention what's not to be done. I'll
edit it, inshallah.
For me to know, anyone to know that is
the translation matching authentic
hadith or not, you first see the
translation of
when Allah says, when the Quran says,
"Yad Allah, yad, hands."
If the translator translates that hand,
that means he is following sahih hadith.
Otherwise,
many will translate power of Allah.
Because in Arabic, yadun means hands.
But
in English, hand can have a variety of
meanings.
I'm holding my family doesn't literally
mean I'm having my hands around my
family always. Holding them, supporting
my family.
Hand can also mean like power.
So, when yad is mentioned, some of the
people translate it as variety of
meanings.
But according to the hadith, sahih
hadith that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has hands, he has hands.
Laisa kamithlihi shay, it is not like
any other hand, not like your hand or my
hand.
He has hands.
Not like yours and mine. So, many people
when they translate, they try and give
more of the derived meaning.
So, therefore, to know a translation
whether it's
based on authentic hadith only, that
does not mean if a translation doesn't
call hands as hands, it has to be
rejected totally.
Like Abdullah Yusuf Ali also doesn't use
the hand for hand.
But because of its other advantages,
so this translation amongst the
translations that have been done lately,
in the past few decades, I would say
Sahih International is masha Allah one
of the best. Farooq Azam is also
alhamdulillah amongst the new. When I
say new, doesn't mean one year or two
years. It means the last few decades.
When I say new,
it can be a few years also.
This translation also is a translation
which is modern translation, unlike
some of the archaic
English.
And it's also a good reference that can
be given
to a non-Muslim also.
This translation of the Noble Quran
by Dr. Muhammad Taqi-ud-Din al-Hilali
and Dr. Muhsin Khan is amongst the
new, very popular translations.
And why do I say new popular means
that previously
in the Mujamma,
that is the Holy Quran Printing Press
of Saudi Arabia, you know, that prints
the maximum number of Quran in the
world.
How many people have visited the
Mujamma, the Holy Quran Printing Press
in Medina, outskirts of Medina? 1 2 3
Mashallah. How's it?
Great, alhamdulillah.
They have the best of machines. They
have the Heidelberg machines.
Who knows what's a Heidelberg machine?
The Heidelberg machines in printing are
the best available. So, if you know,
technically if you have got a Heidelberg
machine, you have got it.
If you know about media, what cameras
they're using, what are the model, you
come to know that they are the best.
So, they have the best of printing
machines, seven-color machines. They
have single color, two color. And that
goes in print media, which we will not
be discussing in this training program
at all. But when you go and you know
what machines they have in the complex
that they have, alhamdulillah. They
print millions of copies, mashallah.
Millions of copies and they distribute.
And when I had gone many years back, it
was 27 languages. Now, I think they may
have reached 40, 50. I don't know. Allah
knows. I'm having checked up. When I had
gone last, that was
maybe 20
or 15 years back.
Because one of my teachers, mashallah,
Dr. Abdur Raheem
who is head of the department of the
Medina University logo who started
Arabic for the non-Arabs. He later on
became head of the translation
department and yet he is alhamdulillah.
He is very elderly. May Allah give him
more life, longer life. Alhamdulillah.
That time it was about 28 languages. Now
it might have gone
40, 50, I don't know. So this
press
used to print Abdullah Yusuf Ali
until
maybe
like 10, 15 years back. They have
changed to
the Noble Quran
Taqi-ud-Din Hilali
and Dr. Muhsin Khan. So this translation
is very good for a Muslim.
For a person who believes
Quran is the word of God, who believes
in Sahih Hadith, who agrees with it. So
for a Muslim
it is good, very good. Yet has certain
negative factors. But for the
non-Muslims, I don't recommend it at
all.
Why?
I'm not here to
criticize any translation. All these are
great scholars. I'm nothing in front of
them.
But as a da'ee I have to give the points
because as a da'ee I have experience in
dawah, speaking to non-Muslims. If you
read the translation of Surah Fatiha
I will not say everything. I'll just
come to the main point. The last verse
says, "And guide us not to the path of
those who have earned your anger and
have gone astray." So they give in
brackets, "Gone astray, Jews and
Christians."
So in bracket it mentioned Jews and
Christians.
Now in the text the translation there's
no Yahud and Nasara.
Surah Fatiha
You know it says, "Those who have earned
your anger, such as the Jews." Brackets.
"Nor of those who went astray, such as
the Christians."
So if a Christian reads the Quran and
the first paragraph he reads the Surah
Fatiha and says that guide us to the
straight path, the way of those on whom
you have bestowed your grace, not the
way of those who have earned your anger
brackets such as the Jews, nor of those
who have entered astray such as the
Christians.
No translation should be literal
translation, not addition. I do agree in
the footnotes it's mentioned this hadith
says that those have earned their anger
are Yahud and those have gone astray are
Christians.
Fine, it's right, but Allah doesn't say
that.
Allah knows the word Yahud and Nasara.
You are used it.
All this you can mention in the
footnotes, I have no problem. But I
disagree with anyone mentioning anything
in brackets unless it's a grammar-wise
requirement.
Like grammar-wise you may have a
requirement
because grammatically it can have two
meanings.
So you give an indication, brackets can
be there
to help person understand the grammar of
that language, not to
change.
Put in the footnote. So the major
drawback of this Noble Quran is it has
too many brackets.
Which
didn't Allah know?
Fine, you can give explanation.
So if there's a problem in the grammar
and you're trying to put brackets to
make the person understand
grammatically, no problem.
If you have a comment, put in the
footnote.
But when you put in brackets, it's
assumed that Allah has said this.
Which is not the case.
So the major drawback, though Noble
Quran has become now lately one of the
more popular
translations promoted.
Very good work, but the brackets are
Some people have asked them, "Okay,
we'll use the translation without
brackets." Some agreed, some didn't
agree. Many revisions have taken place
of this in a short span because of the
popularity. But I personally don't
recommend it to be given to a
non-Muslim, but if a Muslim wants to
read it, good. Again, this Noble Quran,
this is the concise form.
This is the concise form, I think. Do
you have the nine volumes?
It is there in my personal library, but
uh these are books
some selected books.
This is the Noble Quran, the English
translation, nine volumes. This is the
detailed one.
Which will come to the tafsir part, I
think.
They will be having a separate section
for Quran with tafsir.
Abdullah Yusuf Ali also has a tafsir,
but a small one. But the ones which are
very voluminous,
so this personally I don't recommend to
give to a non-Muslim. The Muslims want
to read, they should read a variety,
this should be read.
But if you want to read one translation
also, as a Muslim I have no problem,
but as a dahi
to do dawah to others,
read others and even this. So that many
a times if you don't know what is the
reference. One very good point of this
translation is alhamdulillah, they have
given multiple references from Bukhari
and Muslim, alhamdulillah.
So I would recommend you to read it.
Must.
For you.
But it may not be the most appropriate
translation to be given to the
non-Muslims. That does not mean you will
yet come up with uh hundreds of
non-Muslims who have read this
translation and have accepted Islam.
Hundreds.
Because Allah's kalam has got such power
that even if you don't do a very good
work, alhamdulillah, it has its impact.
And this is a very good work,
alhamdulillah, Noble Quran. Their target
while writing may not have been
non-Muslims.
It was mainly Muslims. So they
especially for the Muslims, if you want
a translation with which you can
understand the Quran and with reference
from Bukhari, Muslim and the other sahih
hadith, this is the best that I know of.
The best.
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun
rasul.
Muhammad [music]
Rasulullah
>> [singing]
>> Allah
Allah
Allah Allah
>> [music]
[singing]
>> Allahu Akbar Muhammad Rasulullah
Muhammad Rasulullah
Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah
Allah Allah [music] Allah Allah Allah
Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah